anybody or any country that does
extraordinarily well becomes a model for
others to emulate if Alex Rodriguez has
a fantastic season suddenly every kid is
going to have their swing try to be like
Alex Rodriguez's Chinese the Chinese
economy has had you know three decades
of spectacular growth and it's only
natural that a lot of people around the
world are trying to emulate the growth
the Chinese have had more importantly
they've managed to achieve this growth
while retaining a thorium system it has
liberalized around the margins but not
at the core and so for a lot of
authoritarian rulers a lot of tyrants
around the world they would love to be
the next China they would love to grow
rapidly develop all sorts of wonderful
new capabilities but not give up their
power at the center and so the that's
the root of the idea that the Beijing
consensus is a new positive role model
for the world displacing liberalisation
or democracy or capitalism and so forth
I think that's all a lot of hooey
because the trick that the Chinese have
managed to pull off requires
extraordinary technocratic skill it
requires great domestic sources of
strength and and opportunity and even
then it's not really a long-term game
the Chinese growth that has occurred is
at the early stages of economic and
political development what it will
achieve is what we all would love it to
achieve which is first of all a more
dynamic global economy second of all a
dramatic rise in the standard of living
in China taking hundreds of millions of
people out of poverty and third setting
up the Chinese for an advance into true
modernity that will actually allow their
people and their political system to
partake of a lot of the good things of
the
world and join with other nations in a
cooperative way the fact is that there
is no reason to believe that you are
going to have uninterrupted growth
continued tyranny and nastiness in China
down the road something's got to go
either the growth will stop as they hit
barriers because the society isn't free
enough either the country will hit a
demographic roadblock or it'll break up
in some kind of way or the political
system will liberalize and you'll end up
continuing the growth trajectory with a
more harmonious and positive and
democratic domestic order now all of
that means that China is set to become
an increasingly large player in the
globe but it can't and it won't be able
to do so on the terms it wants what the
Chinese rise to power has brought it is
an opportunity to be free of Western
chiding and Western countering but if
the Chinese use that power poorly if
they antagonize all their neighbors they
will find their neighbors flocking to
the United States for protection and if
the Chinese don't ultimately do the
kinds of domestic reforms that are
necessary for them to reach the next
levels of development they'll find their
wonderful rise stagnating a bit or going
into chaos so essentially I think we
should applaud what's happened in China
and I think that it will only have
positive benefits down the road for
everybody the Chinese and others and I'm
not worried by it although it does mean
that the United States has to get used
to other people having an important say
in the world